bienvenue à la facture on vous le dit
souvent l'inspection pré-achat d'une
maison c'est absolument essentielle mais
encore aujourd'hui des courtiers tentent
de vous influencer dans le choix d'un
inspecteur comme vous allez le voir un
sérieux coup de barre s'impose
[Musique]
la vie d'Anastasia le cul nuque a été
bouleversé après l'achat malheureux
d'une maison à revenu près de
Rivière-du-Loup sa ville natale
de cauchemar de vice-pidemment façon que
les gens veulent pas vivre
[Musique]
cette fâcheuse expérience la conduite a
quitté sa carrière d'infirmière pour
devenir inspectrice en bâtiment mon
inspection s'est faite oui on a décidé
des problèmes non c'était pas une belle
inspection c'est là que j'ai eu le
déclic de dire je vais amener de la
rigueur puis de la compétence en
inspection
détentrice de plusieurs diplômes membres
d'une association d'inspecteurs elle
veut éviter à ses clients de vivre ce
qu'elle a vécu je veux mes clients
soient bien encadrés fait que c'est pour
ça je fais l'inspection
après s'être bâti une clientèle le
nombre de ces inspections à diminuer
sans raison apparente jusqu'à ce qu'un
courtier l'appel indianastasia on se
voit pas en inspection parce que tu nous
fais peur
on s'est concerté les maisons de
courtage puis on veut pas avoir en
inspection
affirmation est énorme mais plausible il
y a un mot pour cela absolument après la
diffusion du cri du coeur de cette
inspecteur nous avons reçu l'an dernier
plusieurs témoignages similaires venant
de diverses régions du Québec je peux
vous dire que la bel est bien une liste
noire pour les inspecteurs
trop rigoureux les courtiers immobiliers
aiment un inspecteur en bâtiment qui
n'explique pas trop les problématiques
observées c'est malheureusement pas un
cas isolé moi je suis la cible de ça
également l'un d'eux Nicolas Leblanc de
La Firme oly speak a accepté d'un
témoigner je sais que certains courtiers
vont dire Oli Spek soit je sais parce
que des clients me l'ont dit oly speck
lui non il rentre pas ici
si vous amenez à l'ispeak on n'accepte
pas votre offre d'achat on le veut pas
qu'au point non c'est pas acceptant
c'est pas déontologie Joël Charron
connaît bien la Loi sur le courtage
immobilier car il est à la fois avocat
courtier ainsi que président de
l'Académie de formation immobilière du
Québec courtier dans son travail en
vertu de règlement sur les conditions
d'exercice on travaille doit être
empreinte d'objectivité il peut pas
s'immiscer dans ce processus là d'autant
plus que ça fait pas partie de ça
compétence on ne veut pas d'inspecteur
sévère au Québec de la part des
courtiers on ne veut pas ça le premier
objectif du courtier c'est que la
transaction passe qu'on se rend chez le
notaire et puis qu'on touche notre
commission qu'attend l'oasique pour
ramener à l'ordre ces courtiers la
vice-présidente de l'organisme qui
chapeaute les courtiers immobiliers
évitent de répondre en déplaçant la
responsabilité sur les inspecteurs le
problème principal vous savez c'est que
les inspecteurs ne sont pas encadré
contrairement à ce que recommande loi
cuit depuis des années des années les
inspecteurs devraient être encadrés
alors le niveau de compétence diffère
d'un inspecteur à l'autre
revenons à Rivière du Loup désormais
Anastasia Luc neck enregistre ses appels
téléphoniques provenant de clients dont
voici quelques extraits
avec toi que je parle de l'agence
immobilière
l'inspection qu'est-ce qu'il vous
reproche les courtiers d'avoir des gros
rapport il y a un courtier qui m'a dit
Anastasia et dit moi je prépare mes
clients à peu près 50 pages négatif
puis ton rapport il y a 80 100 120 pages
oui mon rapport est long mais là faut
que tu diminues 10 minutes ton nombre de
pages puis là tu vas rentrer sur notre
liste d'inclusion
ce courtier c'est Denis Desjardins de
l'agence Proprio Direct nous l'avons
joint alors qu'il se trouvait en Alabama
est-ce que le nombre de pages de ces
rapports vous pose problème
des rapports conditions ne lui avez-vous
pas dit que ces rapports d'inspection
sont trop longs contiennent trop de
pages et que cette nuit au ventre de vos
maisons
pour l'exclure c'est absolument faux
absolument faux écoutez bien ce qui le
dit lors de cette rencontre kanastasia
luchnique a enregistré à son insu
comment fait ton travail sauf que pour
nous ça devient un obstacle à la
réussite de notre objectif qui est
devant la maison quand tu arrives avec
un rapport de 80 à 90 balles il y a
certains moments c'est trop bouée à
l'échec on va 25 30 % des clients qui
connaissent pas ceux qui sont nés au
fait que tu es fait acquis 90 pages là
financièrement ça l'a fait je trouve pas
très très vite
mais c'est Desjardins je ne vous crois
pas une seconde quand vous dites que
vous lui avez jamais dit ça j'ai la
preuve contraire que c'est ça que vous
avez dit
non mais je suis comme je vous dis c'est
de l'interprétation moi je trouve ça
inquiétant clairement le courtier a
manqué d'objectivité cette émission dans
le travail de l'inspectrice en question
pour lui dire comment faire son travail
alors encore une fois il n'a pas la
compétence de faire ça mais il y a plus
cet agence de Rivière-du-Loup à ajouter
sur des fiches descriptives de toutes
les maisons à vendre une clause le
vendeur se réserve le droit d'accepter
ou non le choix de l'inspecteur de
l'acheteur est-ce conforme à la loi
selon moi non parce qu'on vient
restreindre le droit à l'acheteur ou
choisir son propre inspecteur en
bâtiment la clause est pas illégale en
soi l'organisme dont le mandat est de
protéger le public croient que c'est
l'usage de cette clause qui peut poser
problème si c'est pour écarter des
inspecteurs qui seraient trop rigoureux
là on a un problème mais la clause en
soi n'est pas illégale puis l'acheteur a
le loisir de la refuser comme Anastasia
Lecu ne fait pas partie de la liste
d'inclusion de proprio directes de
rivières du loup cette clause a pu
justifier l'annulation de plusieurs de
ses inspections
tu aurais fait des gens ça me dérange
pas
si tu fais annuler mes inspections c'est
non c'est illégal tu as pas le droit de
faire ça
et c'est condamnable
dans une plainte déposée au syndic de
loi CQ l'association des inspecteurs en
bâtiment du Québec à utiliser des mots
très durs pour décrire les pratiques de
Proprio Direct et de Rivière du Loup
tromperie apparence de collusion
manquement à la déontologie immorale une
honte pour la profession de courtier
cette méthode de travail là de cette
agence là
est inacceptable c'est les méthodes qui
sont trompeuses
picsant aussi du flammatoire puis qui
sera pas toléré de l'association
l'association n'a-t-elle pas raison de
dire que c'est une honte pour les
courtiers
prononciation comme on le fait on va les
enquêter et puis advenant le cas où
est-ce que des infractions
déontologiques qui sont commises on va
prendre action c'est à dire qu'on va
déposer une plainte disciplinaire ce
sera au comité de discipline de se
prononcer Anastasia le clinique a déposé
une requête en injonction contre deux
courtiers de deux agences Proprio Direct
et immeubles glmc pour que ces ce
qu'elle appelle la diffamation envers
elle estime avoir perdu 155 inspections
en deux ans et réclame plus de 211 000
dollars pour perte de revenus et
dommages à sa réputation j'espère en
fait que la juge va comprendre que j'ai
juste réussi à trouver la parcelle de
d'un iceberg
puis que ça soit dénoncé à grandeur du
Québec
[Musique]
pour des raisons liées à cette poursuite
les deux courtiers ont refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue télévisée dans des
déclarations écrites déposées à la cour
il n'y en bloc les affirmations
d'Anastasia dans l'attente d'un jugement
elle a quitté le bassin Laurent et œuvre
maintenant dans la région métropolitaine
je suis parti parce que ma santé en
dépendait
c'est pas vrai que je te demande
inspectrice
puis c'est pas vrai que je dois fermer
mon entreprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la Cour a rejeté la requête en
injonction interlocutoire donc la
demande urgence pour que ça c'est la
diffamation contre madame Lucques c'est
donc la requête en injonction permanente
qui va suivre son cours par ailleurs
Proprio Direct la bannière nous a écrit
pour nous dire qu'elle n'a jamais
autorisé ses courtiers à boycotter ou
diffamer un inspecteur